Hello Marvelites.
I'm Ryan a.k.a.
Agent M. I've got Bill Rosemann.
Hey there.
Eric Monacelli.
And we just debuted the
trailer for Marvel's Avengers.
Let's take a look.
Cap, what's going
on over there?
Uh!
Start the Chimera.
What's your status?
You should head back.
No, stay on task.
There's still civilians
on this bridge.
(WHISPERING) Captain.
Damn it, they played us.
No.
You guys just saw the
trailer for Marvel's Avengers,
and oh, boy, very
exciting, boys.
Yes.
And so we're here to
tell you all about six
things we just learned
about Marvel's Avengers.
You guys, ready?
- We're ready.
- OK.
First things first.
Yes.
We have a release date.
- We do.
Amazing.
We do.
It's May 15, 2020.
And a lot of platforms.
A lot of platforms.
So it'll be on PS4,
Xbox, PC, and Stadia.
Woo.
I like that.
Very exciting.
OK so, number two, we know
who the Avengers team is.
We do indeed.
Can you give us that roster?
Well, what would the
Avengers be without a leader
like Captain America?
Who is played by Jeff Shine.
RYAN PENAGOS: Right hand
man, flying through the sky,
the armored avenger, Iron Man.
ERIC MONACELLI: By Nolan North.
BILL ROSEMANN:
RYAN PENAGOS: How about the
guardian god of thunder, Thor?
ERIC MONACELLI: That would
be Travis Willingham.
RYAN PENAGOS: How about the
ultimate spy, Black Widow?
ERIC MONACELLI: Laura Bailey.
RYAN PENAGOS: And
you know sometimes,
you need a doctor on your team
that may unleash a rage beast.
I'm talking about Dr.
Bruce Banner and the Hulk.
ERIC MONACELLI: Troy Baker.
RYAN PENAGOS: Oh.
You guys, and you didn't
even rehearse this.
You guys are wonderful.
So we got to talk
about the game story.
We learned a lot about what the
story is for Marvel's Avengers.
BILL ROSEMANN: So
as you saw tonight,
the game story begins on A-Day.
It's a celebration
of the Avengers.
However, during A-Day,
tragedy strikes.
There is some devastation.
Things go south.
Is it a setup?
ERIC MONACELLI: Who knows?
BILL ROSEMANN: We'll see.
They're blamed for the tragedy.
ERIC MONACELLI: They are blamed.
BILL ROSEMANN: They're
blamed for the devastation.
But five years later,
a new evil arises
and our only hope for the world
is for Earth's Mightiest Heroes
to reassemble once again.
ERIC MONACELLI: I like it.
All right.
That's all we can
talk about the story.
But the story's only
part of the whole thing.
We also learned
about the game play.
ERIC MONACELLI:
The gameplay, yes.
So we'll have a single
player campaign,
which covered off most of
what we heard in the story.
But also we'll be
continuing that narrative
for years and years to come in
a multiplayer four player co-op.
ERIC MONACELLI: You just hit two
of the most important points.
Because single player
and co-op and that
we're going to be
playing for a long time.
BILL ROSEMANN: Which
means there will
be new additional
heroes and regions
that will cost you nothing.
ERIC MONACELLI: Zero.
RYAN PENAGOS: Bam, bam.
OK, finally, we learned
that the game is
going to be super customizable.
BILL ROSEMANN: Yeah.
ERIC MONACELLI: Yeah.
RYAN PENAGOS: Tell
me about that.
ERIC MONACELLI: So
we'll have our heroes
that you can get for--
BILL ROSEMANN: Free.
ERIC MONACELLI: And those
heroes will have outfits,
some originals, some of
your fan favorite outfits,
some classic outfit.
Just everything
you could try on.
Check them out.
And we'll have all these
different heroes that we'll
be unlocking over time.
BILL ROSEMANN: And
some all new designs.
ERIC MONACELLI: New designs.
BILL ROSEMANN: That Crystal
and Marvel Games collaborated
on made just for this game.
ERIC MONACELLI: It's
pretty exciting.
BILL ROSEMANN: Yes.
ERIC MONACELLI: Very exciting.
ERIC MONACELLI: Lots more for us
to talk about, share, and learn
for Marvel's Avengers.
Gentlemen.
Thank you very much.
BILL ROSEMANN: Reassemble.
ERIC MONACELLI: Let's
go have some fun.